Jo.
Když se podíváš na dnešní možnosti, myslím, že je to
taky velmi důležitá otázka — říct si:
jaká je roadmapa, jak moc
jsou tyhle systémy lepší
a jak moc složité
circuit budeme schopní spouštět?
A proto jsme vyvinuli velmi důležitou metriku,
které se říká quantum volume.
Někdy si v populárním tisku můžeš přečíst nebo uslyšet
počet qubitů, víš,
jako měřítko pokroku.
Řeknu ti rovnou, že
pouhý počet qubitů v počítači není
dobré měřítko pokroku.
Pokrok se musí měřit
úrovní složitosti circuit, který dokážeš spustit.
Qubity v těchhle dobrých počítačích dnes ještě nejsou dokonalé
a mají chyby, které způsobuje propojení
systému s vnějším světem.
Samotná síla těchhle qubitů —
provázanost a tyhle vlastnosti —
z nich dělá zároveň výkonné
i citlivé na interakci
a spojení s vnějším světem.
Takže potřebuješ snižovat chybovost,
zatímco zvyšuješ počet qubitů.
To je to, co je tady znázorněno.
Co opravdu chceš dělat, je pohybovat se po úhlopříčce,
a quantum volume je metrika, která zahrnuje
obě tyhle veličiny i některé další klíčové faktory.